a scene of devastation is what is left
from the Syrian government's intense
aerial bombardment and ground offensive
in ad-lib the last stronghold of the
Syrian opposition
despite rounds of talks and shaky
ceasefires this push has triggered one
of the largest waves of displacement in
the nine-year conflict civilians leaving
everything behind and heading north
towards the Turkish border
I've already been displaced twice maybe
I will have to move again I don't know
what to say the situation is very bad we
heard about the ceasefire but never
witnessed it on the ground just
displacement and suffering the UN says
at least five hundred twenty thousand
Syrians have been displaced in the last
two months alone many children are among
them it is not only the violence but
also the biting winter called that is
making the situation worse in adlib for
the late comers the conditions are basic
they struggle to keep their children
warm everything is gone where is my home
I built here 60 years ago is nothing
left of it now we are living in tents
that sheep wouldn't live in the Syrian
forces backed by Russia retake villages
and towns they are targeting civilians
according to the World Health
Organization at least 53 health
facilities have been forced to suspend
their services since the beginning of
the year because of the fighting Mohamed
who serve around 150 Cubs by the border
200 patients daily I have limited
resources and risk being bombarded by
the regime at any time may God help us
serve our people Syrian government
forces have been advancing inside adlib
territory that was meant to be a
de-escalation zone Mandana we won't go
back and let the regime withdraws from
our lands we're asking the opposition
forces to intervene and repel the Syrian
army the Turkish government is accusing
Damascus of forcing civilians to flee
towards its border there are already at
least 3.5 million Syrian refugees in
Turkey which is why officials here say
they want to stop another
mass influx of Syrians entering the
country but there are now seven hundred
thousand civilians stuck right behind
this border crossing on the Syrian side
looking for safety cynalco sólo al
Jazeera hata turkey-syria border